[Musica]
determinante riterreste oggi falange
trova l'errore science nelle foto come
sempre veniamo s'è fatto che tutti voi e
se faccio più tutti dovrete scrivere le
vostre risposte nei commenti quaggiù e
alla fine del video vediamo se avete
vinto con il suo finto io siete pronti
patatine pop corn e lasciate un bel
l'aics questo video
iniziamo subito con la prima immagine
che vedete qua allora cosa c'è di
sbagliato in questa immagine
[Musica]
analizziamo bene forse delle banche se
voi avete già individuato come sede
sbagliarsi vetroni commenti per la
numero uno
[Musica]
forse non sono sicura se sia una
prospettiva però mi sembra che questo
maghetto qua ci sia e poi qualcomm baia
core possibile quindi io dico che la
cosa sbagliata e il laghetto scrivete
voi la vostra risposta di commenti per
il numeroso si era questo che il
laghetto non il fiume scusate non il
laghetto è un fiume non continua quindi
queste sposterete risorse giusto avete
fatto un punto quindi sono a un punto
numero due di sbagliato in questa
immagine
[Musica]
allora è un vampiro
a quanto pare gli studenti oppure
signore con i denti molto affilati anche
le unghie rughe e si fa la barba forse i
bambini non si fanno barba a questa
forse riuscì a capirla se avete di
subire di monkey ius viene intendete un
po di bambini oltre a twilight discovery
per i bambini che comunque praticamente
scrivete già la risposta sarà staffetta
ma dicono i miei film di vampiri i
bambini non si possono specchiare allo
specchio perché non vengono riflessi
nello specchio
quindi penso che sia questa la cosa che
non è possibile che si sta spaccando lo
specchio
vediamo per questo le soste gamberi non
appaiono nei misti che non si possono
specchiare mi dispiace per i mobili ma
non si possono specchiare quindi è stato
due punti prossimo numero 3 cosa c'è di
sbagliato in questa foto
[Musica]
mi viene da dire che se l'orso polare
sta appoggiato qua
il pezzo di ghiaccio si rivolterebbe
dall'altra parte perché pensa non è
distribuito e commette però mi sembra
strano che la risposta sia così ovvia
vediamo se c'è qualcos'altro sono tempi
non sono mi viene in mente nient'altro
quindi 23 scrivete la vostra risposta
nei commenti vediamo se e come dicevo
non era questo ma è una risposta allora
in realtà popolare vive al polo nord
invece pinguini vivono al polo sud
quindi non era possibile che stavano
assieme quarta immagine cosa centrare
questa immagine
mary a pieni di lotte che si sono 38 le
hits in cotto
luca mi scusassi stia di strani questa
foto poi avete visto ce l'avete visto
scrivetelo nei commenti
questa è la numero di fatto mi sento non
analizziamo bene la donna e sembra
abbastanza normale sta versando il latte
poi ho capito non sono sicura perché la
risposta sia mi stupì da allora ripeto
che mi viene in mente che sta verso
della thema è vuoto qua quindi non so se
l'ha finito versando parte oppure è
questo l'errore forse non lo sto qui
fedelmente nient'altro spirito e la
nostra risposta dei commenti
vediamo sia questo è viva stato a tre
punti anche voi se avete scritto che non
sarà il latte nella cosa avete un punto
anche voi numero 5 cosa c'è di strano
questa foto deserto quindi siamo nel
deserto ci sono questi qualcosa che mi
viene in mente che la palma non dovrebbe
esserci nel deserto oppure voi avete
notato qualcosa altro scrivetemi come kg
proprio risposta del numero 5 e abbiamo
vedere qual è la risposta ragazzi la
risposta è che non ci sono le ombre dei
cammelli creare questa oro quest'ora
difficile numero 6
abbiamo londra cosa c'è di strano con
sbagliato in questa foto
allora del bus a due piani esistono
davvero non solo a londra quindi non ci
trovo niente di sbagliato persona
cartellino cosa che mi viene in mente
che mi sembra che questa macchina stia
quando nella corsia in cui le macchine
sembra che stia andando nella corsia
sbagliata questa macchina azzurra quindi
questa è l'unica cosa che mi viene in
mente noi numero 6 scrivete la vostra
risposta nei commenti vediamo no è
perché in uk si guida a sinistra e non a
destra quindi in realtà dovrebbe essere
il contrario questa strada blu però 7 ha
subito fortunatamente questo è
abbastanza semplice volete bene
guardate bene guardate bene scrivete la
vostra risposta nei commenti il numero 7
allora la cosa che avevo notato subito e
che il vento in base appunto agli alberi
bat sinistra però nel il fumo
la casa dal camino va a destra quindi
non ha senso questa cosa quindi quello
che state sbagliate questo il fumo che
viene dalla calda di rete nei commenti
numero 7 vediamo
sì evviva finalmente salva 4 punti anche
mi avete scritto questa risposta vita
non ho qualche poté quanti punti avete
fatto allora numero 8 questa è la foto
in un altro video
la cosa peggiore è che in un vicolo
nemmeno quale fosse la risposta comunque
provò a ripensarsi cioè gli viene invece
una cosa ma non so se quello no che sì
me lo sono ricordato quindi numero 8
scrivete voi la risposta nei commenti io
non so già scrivete scrivete guardate
bene guardate bene avete visto
ok da tutta la risposta allora io mi
ricordo che avevo detto che l'altezza
dello specchio non rispecchiava qua
legame tra che dovrebbe essere un po più
su mi sembra un po più giù ma gaza la
risposta era se non spoglio che la
posizione delle braccia e imperfetta
nello specchio vediamo si è riflesso
delle braccia e sbagliato è invertito
quindi se lo avete indovinato
un altro punto addio questo è ancora più
difficile il numero 9 bisogna trovare
quattro cose sbagliate in questa foto o
nell'ultima però ragazzi allora è
l'ultimo troviamo quattro così spagna
tema ci appostiamo quale se possiamo
fare allora analizziamo bene allora la
prima l'ho trovata guardate anche voi e
scrivetele poi tutte nei commenti
la prima è che parli ma forse assorbente
e toro ma non c'è grosso quindi le
macchine non si possono formare fermare
cerchiamo le altre o che trovato anche
l'altra voi ma non mano scrivetelo nei
commenti se le trovate
anzi prima le cerco e poi vi dico quali
sono questi le trovate anche voi
io né trovato un'altra questo due forse
un'altra ma non sono sicura che sia un
errore non trovo non trovo la quarta
guardan
voi avete trovato inter 4 no ragazzi non
mi voglio prendere vuole trovare la
quarta quali sono le tube
ok ragazzi forse ho trovato la quarta
non sono sicura che sia un errore
voi avete iscritti nei commenti ora vi
do la mia risposta non so se vedremo fra
poco allora da numero uno questa cosa il
semaforo
sicuramente è un errore quindi il numero
uno poi a numero 2 altissimo sicure
cento per cento che un errore
vediamo se avete individuato anche voi
ed è questo c'è scritto il 32 dicembre e
ovviamente ti sembrerà una stretta due
giorni quindi questo sicuramente il
secondo errore poi per il terzo
l'unica cosa strana che vi viene in
mente è qua questi cavi del come si
chiama questi traumi
non so però se un errore questo e poi
nessun altra cosa
per fortuna valutata perché in realtà
stavo per dire che il 4 e traorè sono
queste ruote perché non sembra cambiato
per water questo tram 1 2 3 4 da sono
assume l'auto mi sembra un po strano ma
non lo so però ho notato adesso un'altra
cosa che forse è il quarto errore cioè i
fili si interrompono qua com'è possibile
non sono attaccati a niente quindi dico
che è questo il quarto errore non sono
sicura dal di terzo cioè questi film qua
ma vediamo lo avete scritto voi nei
commenti siete pronti all'ultima grande
ripetizione 20 o
no allora il primo raggiunto del
semaforo
il secondo era che non ci sono le porte
questo trauma cosa stessero dall'altra
parte premete mostra del tablet tardi
poi l'allerta è che non ci sto i binari
quindi dove stanno aldo attenzione
perché quella dei capi dei figli non me
la segna come errore ma secondo me è un
errore perché dove cavolo umana comunque
la quarta era questo del 32 dicembre
quindi io ne ho azzeccato una e due
quindi avevo quattro punti a 6 punti
quindi mi punti totali sono sei
fatemi sapere nei commenti voi quanti
punti avete fatto sì mi avete battuta o
se avete fatto meno punti di me ho più
di me
fatemi sapere se volete vedere altri
video trovare il blu trova l'errore o
indovinelli questo un fatto a fare
questi video assieme a boyette che poi
vederlo più commenti vedo che
ragionamenti avete fatto voi mi diverto
sempre un pato quindi potere soprattutto
nei commenti ovviamente lasciate un bel
like e ora vi lascio qua qua drogate
linee su cui potete cliccare per vedere
il prossimo video i miei prossimi video
cliccate su quella che preferite è un po
la visione